and we are now joined by magnus carlsen
after day one and the semi-finals and
minus we are saying
of course we are surprised we haven't
seen you lose any
day ones in the knockout stage so far so
um how are you feeling after this
oh it's uh really really frustrating
because it feels like
um just a uh a massive
own goal goal in the in
in the second um no sorry in the in the
third game
um because i i i mean
i had a great position from the opening
uh and i just spent too much time there
later on um just
choosing from from a wealth of good
options really
um and then i i miscalculated something
extremely simple and uh
after after that i yeah i started to
lose the thread and
he outplayed me so um
yeah it feels like something that
could have been very easily uh avoided
also also what happened in in the last
game
which is
i mean i i was uh i equalized but there
was nothing
nothing much there at all um but then
i felt like i was getting um
i was getting nowhere really and
suddenly i got this chance
um yeah on my fifth year there abouts
when he took an h5
because if i go queen uh
queen h3 check there um i think in
practice it's
pretty difficult defense uh for instance
king f2 i give a check on
on h4 or erh2 for that matter
h2 is just as good and the thing is
whenever he goes to f1 i
check on i take an h5 i get a
i i go to f3 and i'll take e3 with check
and my king is going to be be active and
this ending is just
horribly unpleasant for him
i guess holdable but in pract in
practice
with his time taking down
um
yeah the the the thing is that uh
before i went for for this g5 i i'd sort
of
i thought i'd calculated this to draw
and i thought queen takes e3 was
my only chance hoping that he takes on
h6 and then i can go
take um take the bishop actually yeah
that's not even close to working
either probably but um and then i mean
i should have should have taken
should have taken um a little bit of
time there to
um to just double check these things
because
i basically in this situation when you
when you're down
um when you're down the game in order to
bring win with black you have to
you have to play perfectly almost you
you cannot
let any chances uh go by and that is
it's really um it's really annoying that
i i didn't
um um yeah that i
that i didn't take that chance to keep
the game going because
i think in that case we could have had a
very different situation
situation there um but overall
obviously he did he did well in the
in in the third uh game but it feels
extremely unnecessary to have lost the
match today yeah
you mentioned that i mean sorry to bring
it up you mentioned that own goal in the
third game magnus was there a key
turning point
um i guess that was the decisive game of
the day
um no the the thing is i had
i had a number of opportunities to go
knight c5 there
with with a great position really
um and uh
obviously i i saw that and i wanted i
wanted more
uh what i'd missed was
as simple as my my thought
was um knight d6
cd6 uh bishop g2
and i thought um
for some reason i i was considering
knight c7 briefly
uh i just go b3 and that's
that's more or less it um
and so i somehow failed to consider that
b3 was not possible on account of c3
after
after other options because otherwise
i'd
never ever go for these positions
because
contrary to um
uh contrary to the knight c5 positions
here the
c d uh here the pawn on d6 covers
um important squares in c5 and e5
and the way it happens in the game it
looks
extremely simple because in reality i've
just
made a very simple positional
mistake and yeah that's
extremely extremely disappointing
because obviously i know that this move
is in general
wrong but i thought somehow i was
following it up with up up with b3 and
that was just really really bad uh
because like any
on on any of the previous moves like any
idiots could go
knight c5 and just dominate the game
really
so overall um
yeah um you should you shouldn't lose
this white and especially
especially not not in this manner
so minus a different situation for you
in the knockout tomorrow than in a
must-win situation to take
it to target so how are you going to
attack that situation
yeah the the situation is um is
completely new to me actually um because
normally in other the tournament
the format we had had last year um
well i would need to win the match but i
wouldn't need to to win it
by by fault
by by full time um i i could
yeah i would have the safety net that i
could still go to to
and and and win when then um
yeah um i have
i have two white games um
so there are chances chances there but
obviously i put myself in a
in a pretty pretty bad situation all
right my mind is we
wish you the best of luck on a very
exciting day tomorrow thanks for joining